I could hear the whole cheered in my
head it was all there till know so much
about to get it out it's a little bit
funny this feeling inside what did you
say your name was again
my name is Reginald Dwight Reginald
that's my granddad's name it's not as a
fat boy from nowhere get to be a sole
man got to kill the person you were born
to be in order to become the person you
want to be I'm thinking of changing my
name to Elton that's my name yeah you
could be the best-selling artist America
a desert who's trying to do something
bold Annie why are you so charming
flashing can you even play the piano in
those
[Music]
they know you are
and just don't kill yourself with drugs
so how does it feel to be a stop
it's never gonna last it's just centered
right well we can arrange it one of this
is going I just hope you realize you're
choosing a knife of being a man forever
don't know why I just sing when I was
ridiculous paraphernalia people don't
pay to see red wine they pay to see out
soon
sorry
[Music]
do you care how much pressure I'm on the
not really I'll still be collecting my
20% along after you've killed yourself
[Music]
I should have tried to be more ordinary
he would never ordinary
[Music]
Morse's shine little boy you look at you
now
[Music]